Scarlet Witch is a fairly new addition
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
although she has a rich and desire comic
history that goes as far back as most of
the Avengers when it comes to getting
her own standalone movie that lengthy
history might actually hurt more than it
helped here's why we think Marvel won't
give Scarlet Witch her own movie
Coulson's not sold Elizabeth Olsen the
actress who plays Scarlet Witch has been
enjoying a nice career list from the MCU
but isn't sold on doing a solo movie she
said quote the pressure of a tent full
movie on my shoulders doesn't feel
comfortable and cook in the meantime
she's taken advantage of the tight
scheduling of the Marvel machine to find
other projects though she's obviously
hesitant Olsen did admit she might be
interested though the story would have
to make sense for how it advances the
world toy trouble
times are changing but not that quickly
Captain America Civil War has the
distinction of having the most female
heroes of all the MCU movie so far and
that's definitely a good thing however
just like Black Widow in the previous
Avengers films Scarlet Witch figures
were scarce to practically non-existent
in the movies initial point line
take this Avengers versus Ultron box set
it's got nine figures nine and while it
doesn't include black widow or Scarlet
Witch two of the film's most important
characters it does manage to find room
for a figure called sub Ultron tyke
Marvel has been working on these
diversity oversights and both Scarlet
Witch and Black Widow eventually got
their own action figures multiple
versions in fact but the historic
reluctance to lean heavily on its female
heroes doesn't bode well for the
possibilities of Scarlet Witch being
allowed to carry a standalone film like
it or not toys are still big business
when it comes to superhero movies if
they don't think a Scarlet Witch toy
will sell it makes a movie even less
likely bonkers backstory Scarlet Witch
is a great character for an ensemble
cast she has a cool look cool powers and
her magic skills are a nice balance to
heroes with check weapons and
hand-to-hand skills but as useful as
that might be there are a whole lot of
problems once you dig a bit deeper Wanda
Maximoff history goes back to the same
Silver Age comics era as the Avengers
with her first appearance coming only a
year after the team's debut
most comic book storylines got pretty
weird in the night
sixe but her set the gold standard for
wacky Wanda and her brother Pietro
better known as Quicksilver were born
after their mother fled their father
more on him later and were adopted by a
guy called the High Evolutionary oh and
they were also raised by a cow yes an
actual cow
her name is Vova and that's actually
only the start of scarlet witch's
weirdness her powers are basically magic
and in both the movies and comics she
gained them by being experimented on
looking back to the comics most of
scarlet witch's powers are actually
channeled through a demon God named
Kazan but she's also gained additional
powers through deals with the character
Mephisto who is basically Marvel's
version of the devil between her having
a cow for a mom and all the business she
does with literal demons making a movie
that's true to her comic roots might be
well a little challenging family film
issues the cinematic right to Marvel's
x-men franchise have been owned by Fox
for a long while with the Marvel
Cinematic Universe owned by Disney the
odds for a crossover are pretty much
non-existent so things can get a little
touchy when you have characters related
to one another spread between the two
companies for decades of comic-book
history it was pretty clearly
established that magneto is Scarlet
Witch and quicksilver's biological
father meanwhile Marvel has since made
that point a bit looser with some recent
storylines that suggest the twins were
never mutants in the first place
possibly in an effort to better match
the film but no matter how you slice it
Scarlet Witch and Magneto have tons of
comic book history together for a movie
to push all that out of the way could
potentially alienate longtime fans too
powerful one of the toughest challenges
in writing a character like Scarlet
Witch is that they haven't actually
established an upper limit to her powers
at various times in the comics she's
rewritten time and shifted realities
resurrected the dead and brought
characters to life out of thin air at
one point she wills the entire mutant
species out of existence in the same way
screenwriters often struggle to come up
with worthwhile challenges for
characters like Superman and Hulk
Scarlet Witch could pose a similar
problem it's one thing to have her save
the day for a few moments at a time in
an ensemble picture but on her own
whipping up a movie like that might be
the one power she doesn't have
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to